après la tempête c'est l'état de choc à
new york plus de 40 morts dans quatre
états ida a été dévastatrice et
meurtrière
jamais la ville n'avait connu de pires
intempéries 80 mm de pluie en une heure
un métro submergés et des passagers pris
de court du jamais vu
c'est le réveil le plus brutal que pour
avoir dit un big d blasio dépassé par
les événements ici dans le quartier de
queens trois personnes sont mortes
noyées dans leur sous sol
non loin de là raul batista nous montre
les dégâts chez lui la veille le
frigidaire servait de barques dans son
sous sol
j'ai tout perdu dit il me serait pu être
pire car le matériel peut toujours être
remplacé mais un maintien
l'état d'urgence a été décrété dans tout
l'état de new york par la nouvelle
gouverneur qui venait à peine d'entrer
en fonction à une ride
et péter nous avions déployé les
ressources additionnelles ya matin
diethelm on pensait pas que les chutes
du niagara allait se déverser sur le
new-jersey l'état le plus touché avec 23
morts dont deux qui étaient pris dans
leur voiture
en pennsylvanie des pompiers venus
porter secours ont été à leur tour pris
par le déluge
les pompiers sont devenus des sinistrés
dit il et ont dû être transportés à
l'hôpital
nous faisons face à une nouvelle réalité
lance bill de blasio faisant référence
aux changements climatiques
cent cinquante mille personnes sont
toujours privées d'électricité rôle
batista lui se demande comment il va
payer son loyer tous ses outils de
travail ont été détruits
nous sommes là pour vous dit il
promettant que ceux qui sont les plus
touchés par ida recevront l'aide
nécessaire ici dans le quartier de
queens les gens continue de nettoyer
leur sous sol l'ouragan ida a été
rétrogradé cyclone post tropical et
poursuit sa route vers le nord mais les
scientifiques avertissent que les
tempêtes vont devenir de plus en plus
puissante à l'avenir à cause du
réchauffement la surface des océans ses
épaules des gunners radio-canada new
york